good afternoon and welcome to a very
special edition of take a break the
reddit revolution
today we look at the events leading up
to this week's insane run on wall street
and
what happens next gamestop's media arc
rise was brought on by an army of day
traders betting against some of wall
street's most powerful firms
the goal artificially send shares higher
in a show of force by redditors on a
forum
called wall street bets well wall street
beds now boast some
6 million followers and in 30 minutes
we're going to chat with the founder of
that reddit group
all about this life-changing week and
how he wants this story to end
and of course we want to give you the
most useful information to understand
the saga
we're going to break down what the
experts have to say about investing when
it comes to that promo
that you could be feeling including
answering some questions that we got on
twitter
and instagram it's january 29th i'm tim
stenoveck in new york and this is take a
break the reddit revolution let's get
going
[Music]
good afternoon we start today's coverage
of the reddit revolution by trying to
answer the question that many have right
now
what the heck happened this week joining
me now to help make a sense of the
market mania is bloomberg markets
reporter sarah poncech
wall street reporter shanael basic and
senior markets editor john authors who
has
covered markets for over 30 years thank
you all for being here sarah i want to
start with you
for people who haven't followed the
story as closely as you have um
what the heck has been happening a lot
has happened this week and
this week has really felt like a year i
can say from my standpoint at least as
i'm sure for many too
but if you really think about it what it
boils down to
is it's as if this war is almost being
fought between
on one side you have the quote-unquote
wall street establishment so hedge funds
short sellers on the other side of that
you have retail traders
particularly those on the wall street
bets
subreddit and this war has really been
waged in the stock market
with stocks the likes of gamestop amc
headphone maker costs it even bled into
build-a-bear tootsie roll at a time i
mean it got
pretty wild pretty out there and when
you look at gamestop part of the reason
that these stocks are really the ones
that are being targeted
by the reddit community is because they
have very high short interest so they're
very heavily shorted by big names like
citron research for example other hedge
funds on wall street
and if you just look if we catch us up
to where we stand right now gamestop
shares are up some
1 700 this month alone
and we've also seen brokerages have to
put restrictions on take restrictions
off it's just been back and forth back
and forth look it's been absolutely wild
john arthur's come in come on in here
because
you've been covering markets for more
than 30 years and and when we take a
step back and we look at
what's happening here is this going to
be one of those historic weeks give us
some context
yes this is this is a this is a
remarkable
week which people are going to be
talking about for years to come
i mean there are one or two precedents
for the technicalities of what happened
volkswagen was very briefly the world's
largest company after it had this epic
short squeeze after
after lehman uh and you've got the
example of two
hedge funds titans doing this to each
other when uh
when carl icahn tried to squeeze uh
bill ackman out of his short on
herbalife a few years ago but
in terms of the breadth of the activity
the fact that it's been coordinated
by true retail investors often uh
investing small
amounts of money in the sheer scale of
what they've managed to wreak
in in terms of the the share price
appreciation that sarah was just talking
about that
there is nothing like this that
i can ever think of as having happened
before this is a
very exciting new phenomenon
and plainly anything that is new in
markets
carries with it very big risks that
we've got to understand
okay well let's we're going to talk
about some of those risks in just a
second i want to bring in janali basic
because she's got her ear to
wall street into some of the biggest
bank shanali what is the establishment
saying
about this week well what's funny is
while there were
definitely definitely definitely
definitely a group of hedge funds that
were
very much hurt by this and there were a
lot of hedge funds that had to rush
and really cover their shorts because
there was such contagion across the
market about this
it's not that this event this week hurt
wall street at large
right why is that because volatility
tends to be good for a lot of these
investment banks that's number one
number two there's a lot of wall street
names in these stocks
for example um you know the big the big
firms with big index providers you know
the black rocks the vanguards
uh jason madrick is a distressed
investor he was a big investor
in amc one of the names uh silver lake
big private equity fund so
there were a lot of wall street names
that won
right so it's kind of oversimplifying if
we think about this
in the sense of pitting the big guy
against the little guy
uh john talk about some of the risks
here that you brought up when you when
you have a week like this
um you know where we actually seen
regulators already be asked about this
and and say that they're going to weigh
in what are the risks associated with
market movements like this
well first of all there's mal
investments
uh gamestop is not worth 25 billion
dollars
yeah i think or whatever its current
market cap
is it just isn't it's going to fall
at some point whoever is holding it at
the point that it falls is going to lose
a lot of money
uh plainly whenever you see miss
valuations as big as this
there is a risk of loss of capital and
in this case when we're talking about
people using
hedge funds can lose money to their
heart's content only very rich people
are allowed to invest in them they don't
deserve protection the kind of people
who are doing this on reddit
plainly their get you get into this
tension between
libertarianism letting the market rip
and paternalism of can
is it really okay to let these people
lose money like this
but beyond that there is the
risk of a bubble the more that uh
capital is distorted the greater the
risk
that money is just starved from the
areas of the economy that need it and
instead
pause into the areas that don't i don't
think gamestop can use it's
if it in the unlikely event that it
doesn't equity
issuance using it's a massive new
uh pe ratio i have no idea how it can
productively use
the equity capital it would rise this is
this is not
efficient allocation of capital
something is going wrong with
the invisible hand so that you know
there are there are risks there
finally and this isn't necessarily a
financial risk but it probably
gets to the heart of the critical risk
that we all face
uh this is being driven by really
serious righteous anger by people who
feel
that uh this is the last they get the
chance to avenge themselves
for 2008. there is danger in such
emotion greed is bad enough
when you're angry you really i think we
would all admit
you are most prone to do something
stupid when you're angry
and a lot of people are angry at
presents that's dangerous and
adding on to this concept of risk when
we talk about risk this is also
why when you look at many of these
brokerages and robin hood has really
been in the middle of this all
but interactive brokers e-trade td
ameritrade for example
why they had to put restrictions on
their accounts and the likes of trading
trading on margin trading on options
just opening new positions
in general uh vlad tenev for example uh
was on bloomberg television last night
it's
come more so to light that if you
actually break down what happened
yesterday so yesterday was the day that
we saw these restrictions were in place
gamestop amc shares all fell we had a
selloff sure they're coming back today
but what it comes down to is the fact
that when
a trade is settling it doesn't just
magically happen
instead the shares sit somewhere for two
days as the trade settles and that's
with
what's called dtcc so the depository
trust and clearing corporation now
someone has to assume the risk for these
shares so when you have a stock like
gamestop that
one day is trading above 500 a share and
the next day could be trading at 100
a share or even less the clearing
corporations
really demand that someone pay up and
pledge collateral
for the risks that they're going to have
to take on so bloomberg reporting
has shown there was a representative
from the dtcc who didn't give exact
numbers
but basically said that the amount of
collateral that had to be pledged to
these clearing corporations
was about seven and a half billion
dollars more than what's usual
um so there are a lot of nefarious
statements and thinking that brokerages
are doing this nefariously
a lot of conspiracy theories and
theories out there but it really does
come down to the concept of risk why
this is all occurring
and yeah yeah actually i had a question
for you john because to sarah's point
here
the reason gtcc makes you post
collateral is to really protect all
these counterparties right
uh have you ever seen a concern in
history or
should there be a concern about some of
these brokerages becoming a more
systemic risk or
um potentially fears of them blowing up
yes uh i mean one one rule of thumb
uh as as a veteran of 2008 is if you're
even
mentioning dtcc if you even feel the
need to
to to to put those initials together you
already have a problem it's much the
same as
if you're even thinking about the
plumbing in your house
that's already bad right um the fact
that this is an issue the fact that
this vital plumbing for the system
becomes a concern
is crucial and yes the uh
one of the the critical ways in which
the the collapse of lehman brothers
turned so quickly into a systemic event
was because uh there were prime
brokerages who
were left with uh very great difficulty
knowing what
to do about uh about all the the trades
uh that they had that that involved
lehman as a counterparty that that
right you you really can freeze up
the entire we're not talking about
obviously lehman
is bigger in absolute terms and
proportionate terms than the players
that are
involved this week but but the mere fact
that this could happen
raises the issue that we need to address
and look i think there's a lot of
questions
about the effect that it had on retail
traders this week because
as we know a lot of retail investors
yesterday found themselves unable to do
basic things
on the apps like robinhood and
interactive brokers that they actually
wanted to do sarah ponce come back in
here because
you had a businessweek story a few
months ago
it was a cover story about the robin
hood revolution
where does robin hood go from here
should they be concerned about potential
reputational damage given that
this was supposed to democratize
investing democratize wall street
but yesterday so many traders found
themselves unable to do basic things in
the app
they've already faced reputational
damage i mean you look at the likes of
all mentioned uh dave portnoy of barcelo
sports who
is saying that robin hood is dead and
tweeting at vlad tenev saying that he's
going to go after him and that what
robin hood is doing is wrong and
you also have politicians like aoc ted
cruz now
tweeting about robin hood saying that
they're basically going after the little
guy this isn't fair hedge funds have
been doing this for years and
robin hood is obviously trying to push
back against that fact and say
look we are on your side we came into
the industry
to help you to quote unquote democratize
investing that's what they say all of
the time
and they're trying to make very clear
that the decision that they made
yesterday
was not their choice they were forced to
do this
still though the belief that there is
something more nefarious going on
whether that be hedge funds
whether that be market maker citadel
forcing them to do this is very
widespread at this point in time and
many of their customers
have already said that they want to go
elsewhere still though if you look at
the apple store you look at the most
popular app
on the apple store yesterday what was it
it was robin hood so people are still
going to robin hood and
name recognition is certainly high look
the story is going to continue to go on
we are so lucky to have all of you
bloomberg chanel bosek sarah poncic john
authors thank you all
so much for your time and for your
insight that was a lot of fun
well coming up the hype was real around
some stocks this week but
don't let fomo drive your investing
strategy next up what the experts are
saying
about making a sound investment decision
that you won't regret
win or lose we'll be back in two minutes
this is take a break
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
our generation's biggest problem climate
change
is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions
transport industry uh buildings
electricity
all of those things everything you need
to know about our changing environment
the politics of global warming we can
and we will deal with climate change
in the fight against climate change
bloomberg green has you covered
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to this special edition of
take a break the reddit revolution
i'm tim stenoveck in new york okay so
let's say you started following the
markets recently you read up on
investopedia articles
now is it your turn to test out a few
strategies well
joining me live from london is bloomberg
personal finance reporter charlie wells
who asked these very important questions
to financial advisors on both sides
of the atlantic charlie my friend thank
you so much for being here
i got to tell you i got a lot of text
messages this week my brother said
that one of his friends made twenty five
thousand dollars
this week doing the gamestop thing um if
you're feeling fomo right now what are
advisors saying for those
who are considering buying gamestop
funny you asked that question i got my
phone right here and a text from my
brother as well saying
quote some law school friends were
trying to convince me to buy some shares
a few weeks ago
i wish i had um so from my brother to
your brother i think there is a lot of
out there and what advisors i've been
calling all week i've been on the phone
with them you know non-stop
is basically you know two letters and oh
do not buy absolutely not the words that
they keep using with me are
casino lottery luck
stuff wow that's literally what they're
saying okay look i want to be careful
here of course we are not giving
financial advice but that is why you
spoke to those folks whose job it is to
give
that financial advice um what are they
saying are there risks that
come with the emotion of of seeing
these triple digit increases in a single
day
for a game stop and other stocks and
then also just reading those stories
about people who've turned hundreds into
thousands and thousands into
tens of thousands right so there's a
sort of euphoric feeling right now and i
think
what these advisors have also been
telling me and these are people who have
literally
signed fiduciary duties to look out in
their clients best interest
is that we're at an interesting moment
with the internet
and investing and so when you combine
those two things you get people
who can share their investment decisions
and those people
have not signed these fiduciary duties
and they are not necessarily
looking out for your best interests and
they may be
you know boosting some of these shares
that you haven't really heard about
since the early 2000s
for reasons that might not be great for
you um and so that's one thing to think
about and another point that advisors
kept making was just
be careful about overconfidence so we're
all home
i'm home we can do research we have got
a lot more time on our hands
um and we can actually understand a lot
of these trading principles better than
maybe we expected
but just because we understand them
doesn't mean that we should do that
charlie what's the biggest mistake an
investor could make with some of these
stocks right now
i think one of the things is believing
some of this quote-unquote
research so a lot of this conversation
is happening in forums
there are people who are presenting you
know quote-unquote research
but what advisors tend to say is kind of
you know second guess this look at this
again
a lot of these commentators are smart
but they're picking up
on sort of certain indicators that might
make them sound like they really know
what they're talking about
but compared to say institutional
investors to hedge funds
they don't have that sort of inside
information
that some of the main players actually
do have to help them make some of these
decisions
charlie we got to set we got to get our
brothers in in touch with each other so
they can
compare stories about uh missing out
bloomberg personal finance reporter
charlie wells
uh charlie thanks so much for your time
this afternoon we appreciate it
well coming up after the break we chat
with a new investor and
we mean really new who happened to
stumble upon a reddit thread that
compelled him to buy gamestop at 65
a share we'll be back in two minutes
this is take a break
access the financial world on demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
our generation's biggest problem climate
change
is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions
transport industry uh buildings
electricity
all of those things everything you need
to know about our changing environment
the politics of global warming we can
and we will deal with climate change
in the fight against climate change
bloomberg green has you covered
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
it was a week for memes this time
look it was another big week for memes
this time they're focused on the market
we're going to be showing you a few of
these throughout the show today
welcome back to this very special
edition of take a break the reddit
revolution
i'm tim stenovec in new york well the
retail trading industry exploded well
before the gamestop frenzy this week
shanali basic has more on the rise of
reddit and robin hood traders
the frustrations with wall street are
running high what started as a way to
share stock tips
is now a revolution the wealthiest one
percent of americans
now account for more than half of the
stock ownership by u.s households
and during this pandemic while wall
street has gotten richer
the same is not true for everyone else
you're witnessing the french revolution
of finance where the
proletariat is rising up to change the
order structure in finance zero fee
trading
on robin hood and other brokerages have
made it much easier for investors to
access the stock market
retail investors accounted for about 25
of stock market trading on the busiest
days last year
that's up from about 10 percent a decade
ago
the retail rush reached a new level this
year with reddit chatroom wall street
bets
drawing attention to highly shorted
stocks like gamestop
and amc trading on options have reached
historic levels
and those particular stocks soared
dramatically
the frenzy is catching many of wall
street's biggest investors off guard
as well as many short sellers i cannot
answer one more phone call
how are you are you okay are you in
business
what about gamestop should i short it
here people i have not spoken to in 20
30 years this has captured the intention
of the america
and every trader and non-trader alike
wall street is dismissing many of these
new investors as
pajama traders or kids that don't know
what they're doing
but many of these stocks like gamestop
amc
and bed bath and beyond that have surged
have caused
billions of dollars worth of losses for
some of the biggest hedge funds
that have bet against them the
establishment i think has to stop
whining about wall street bets and the
ability of individual investors to
express their opinions
on forms that we may not like or
understand or most of them don't
traditionally follow
you know think about the position of
someone on a wall street bets forum for
years
established hedge funds players have
been able to express freely their
investment opinions and things like
conferences
in mediums like television through print
media
and new entrants should be afforded
those same rights and that's exactly
what they're doing
the frenzy in stocks also comes with a
lot of concerns
one of them is that we're in a bubble
and people could lose a lot of money in
the end
another concern is that brokerages like
robinhood or td ameritrade
have clamped down on trading in some of
these stocks
drawing outrage and potentially more
attention from regulators
u.s representative alexandria
ocasio-cortez said congress should take
a look
at why robinhood has stopped investors
from trading some of these stocks
while hedge funds on wall street can buy
and sell these stocks freely
senator elizabeth warren said regulators
should take a harder look at hedge funds
that are using the stock market as their
personal casino
while everyone else pays the price
what's clear
is that from wall street to main street
to washington
the war is not over
well a big thank you to shinali basic
matthew albani and kayla shea
for that coming up after the break why
reddit and gamestop
a match made in investment heaven plus
we're gonna chat with the
founder of that now famous wall street
bets forum we'll be back in two minutes
this is take a break
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
our generation's biggest problem climate
change
is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions
transport industry uh buildings
electricity
all of those things everything you need
to know about our changing environment
the politics of global warming we can
and we will deal with climate change
in the fight against climate change
bloomberg green has you covered
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
gamestop gamestop sitting amongst tesla
and amazon after reddit users
make it a fortune 500 company look at
big bird right there
that's a meme coming from jordan deeb on
twitter
welcome back to this special edition of
take a break the reddit revolution i'm
tim steinovec in new york well for some
retail traders getting in on the
gamestop mania this week turned out to
be just
a coincidence like this next guest here
with bloomberg quick take reporter
jennifer zabasaja hey jen
hey tim i want to bring in our guest
today dara keaney dara became
a first-time trader this week and he's
joining us now from dublin
to share his perspective about the week
that was dara
thanks so much for joining us i mean i
just want to put this into
context a bit for everybody you've been
an investor for what
all of a week i mean why did you decide
to get in
to this whole thing well i just need to
correct you on your fox there jennifer
i've only been an investor for six days
actually and tomorrow is the day
tomorrow's the big anniversary i'm
really excited about it
um i've always i've always had an
interest in the idea of
dabbling in in trading but it just seems
like such a
far away world for me i don't and i
always
like if ever i had money set aside i it
would never be a huge amount of money or
if i had
if i had some some money sitting in a
bank account i thought maybe i could put
it into stocks and shares but
i just i don't know enough about the
world i don't have enough to be
considered a player or to have the
confidence to go into a brokerage and
say
here's here's five here's five figures
show me what you got help me help me
make some money on this
whether it's short term or long term it
was so far from
my world right now but i just decided
you know what this is the week to try
so how exactly did that work i mean were
you aware of what was going on tell us a
bit about the story
okay well aware of it absolutely not no
um so on saturday morning i woke up a
bit earlier than planned
and and i turned on my phone and uh
one of the groups chats that i was in a
friend had said yeah he was reading
something on reddit
and about a and how something could
happen big this week
and he's gonna go in on it and he was
kind of saying look i'm never gonna give
you full-time advice
and there's no there's no conditions on
this i can't guarantee it but
there's something exciting happening if
you're in any way inclined
maybe you should all think about dipping
in or
there's people on that group who are
actually serious players and they
actually they operate in that world so
maybe he was kind of saying look this is
a chance to make some money
but i'm lying in bed i haven't got out
of bed yet and i'm thinking do you know
what this might be
this might be the chance so i'm thinking
how do i do it oh yeah that banking app
that i have
and there's a stocks page on that so i
opened up the app and i looked into it
and lo and behold there is a stocks page
i'd never been on that page before
and i said well i'll set up an account
and there are loads of documents didn't
read one of them i just hit them all
with five or six documents tick yet read
that tick done that
and within three minutes i had myself a
trading account and um
i transferred over what i thought was
200 euro at the time but it turns out it
was 200
because all the trading was done in
dollars again that was brand new to me
and and so then i thought it was afraid
to have it up and running now i'll buy
some gamestop shares
of course even at that stage i didn't
even know what the ticker was what the
acronym was for gamestop so i had to get
out of the app and google that
found out it's gme i know it very well
now and and
searched for gme and found out that it
was 65 a share
i've got 200 to me that makes sense
put it all on gme i'll get three shares
i'll get five dollars back i don't even
know if this works
but everything's going to be fine i hit
buy and
uh i got a notification straight away
going we put it to
we put it to the market when the market
opens on monday morning we'll come back
to you with your shares and i'm like oh
right of course it's the weekend there's
no trading again that's brand new to me
and um forgot all about it and on monday
lunchtime irish time which about
2 30 when the the markets opened in
america i've got another notification to
say
congratulations you've just made your
first purchase you have two shares
of gme at 97 and i'm like hang on a
second i thought it was 65
had to ask my friends what's going on
here and it turns out that the
action over the weekend had pushed it up
so the opening price was different to
the closing price on friday again that's
very new to me
and uh i think even if i've been given
an option at that stage jennifer
i probably would have said no because i
felt i was being heard done by it's 97
dollars a share
this is way too much for me it's only
two shares now all of a sudden but no no
it didn't give me that option it just
bought it for me so i was the
new proud owner of 2.05 shares in gma
and that's how my trading career began
wow
and and so since then i mean have you
just been
watching the news non-stop i mean have
you been following everything that's
been going on
tuesday was a big night for for uh
tuesday was a big day for
for gamestop and instead of sitting on
the couch
uh with my wife watching british and we
were wrapping up bridges on netflix
instead of watching what was going on on
the screen i just found myself i was
just on my phone
refreshing the app all night long
couldn't get my eyes off because it just
kept on going up and going up and
it's just a big story it's going around
the world and obviously
i'm a tiny tiny part of that i only
bought two hundred dollars it seems
weird that i'm now talking to bloomberg
about it
i it's just such a small investment for
me though at the time
i was like oh what will i put in like
should i should i just buy one share
could you buy i didn't even know if you
could buy fractions of shares i thought
i honestly thought i was going to get
five dollars back change by the way from
that initial investment
and i didn't realize you could buy a
portion of a share and it was based down
onto the
the amount of money i put in i was
learning it was all brand new to me
but i'm part of the narrative like it's
a 200
investment on my behalf but there's
there's ten thousand
there's probably more than ten thousand
derikinis around the world who are
making that investment for the first
time
and they're not they don't have to walk
into a brokerage anymore a big company
and they don't have to have a minimum of
five figures
to be to be let past reception it's on
and up
i had done all this in seven minutes
before i even got out of bed on saturday
morning
and i'm as i said it was i know i'm a
tiny player and i know there's lots of
people losing money
and i know there's it's a much bigger
deal for for the target audience over
there in america
but it's very exciting like i'm
first-time trader
kind of got hooked not going to lie to
you i also want to know because i know
you said you have some friends who
have been on some of these messaging
boards there's been a lot of chatter
about sort of the underpinnings of
of what's happening what is the chatter
like like what are you hearing
well look i'm not i'm not a player on
reddit i don't have an account
i've never made a comment or never like
can you like comment i've never
contributed
i've literally been an outsider looking
in and
the comments even yesterday thursday was
a bad day for the share place it was
going down it was tanking people were
panicking
and i even ended up selling one of my
one of my two shares yesterday thinking
i was going to lose it all
and it's it but all the talk was hold
hold up you've probably seen yourself
like the people who know what they're
talking about
they'll do a big post on reddit and
people will will like it and comment and
go
he knows what he's talking about i don't
even understand this to be honest
jennifer i'd love to be able to give you
some inside knowledge
but everyone is saying hold out there's
more to come next week i know there's
lots of time i read something about how
we're gonna
the people like the funding the the mob
mob ruler we're going to try and get it
to a thousand dollars
and but like you read other people who
know what they're talking about
in this world and they're saying you
shouldn't be valuing a gamestop share
for anything more than
15 18 maybe 20 max and the fact that it
was
i think it peaked at 470 this week and
some people think it can go even higher
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna hang around
all day first it's not it's not
something
this isn't the career change for me when
are you gonna get out i mean uh do you
want to collect these profits at what at
what point are you going to
decide to do that i'm going to hold on
uh jennifer because i just i look i'm
not i'm not
i'm not betting with other people's
money here i'm not i'm not investing i'm
not
i'm not a company where i've got big big
clients coming in with their with their
savings
looking to make money it's it's not on
me i don't have any of that guilt
i've already taken out some money
yesterday i sold one share it was a
panic sale i'm not going to lie to you
i'm kind of regretting it now when i
look at the stockpiles
but i didn't know what to do i don't
know what i'm doing so
i've already made a few quid out of that
i'm quids in i'm already up so whatever
happens over the coming days and weeks
it's all profit for me so i'm going to
hang on in there like like a lot of the
people all over
reddit and the live chat on youtube it's
crazy what you see when people know what
they're talking about they're saying no
this is why it tanked on thursday hold
in there friday and see into next week
i might get out but close the business
tonight i don't know but at the moment
i'm planning on holding on because as i
said
this is a small mining fraction of a big
amount of money and
i'm happy to hang in there if anything
it's a learning experience for you right
dara
very very much i'm going to play some of
you arts with my profits
i can see that behind you uh darakini
for us uh in in dublin today thank you
so much for your time and for sharing
your story
tim thanks yeah thanks so much jen what
a fascinating story i love his
excitement too of course so enthusiastic
a big thank you to bloomberg quick take
reporter jennifer zabasaja for that
conversation
well it's time now for quick takes by
the numbers it's where we give you the
numbers that tell the story
this afternoon's number is six million
the reddit forum wall street bets
where it's looking like this gamestop
madness all began
has now topped 6 million users that's up
from
just about 3 million earlier this month
according to dow jones
talk about to the moon well in 2012
jamie rogozinski started a reddit thread
a community for day traders to learn and
play with stock options
fast forward to 2021 that reddit thread
would fuel a rally so astronomical
that hedge funds would lose 14 billion
dollars in a single
day jamie now joins me uh jamie thanks
so much for for being here
look um what has this week been like for
you
well yeah first of all thanks a lot for
having me and it's been
it's been interesting i'd say yesterday
and today have been really been the
crazy days obviously a lot of requests
for interviews
it's not the first time that wall street
vets has made the news certainly
this magnitude it's the first time and
it's also the first time
uh not the first time that i've been uh
in the press so it's
thankfully not something that's entirely
foreign but the magnitude of the story
is is
overshadowing any any of my personal uh
experiences this week i mean i'm baffled
by what
we're seeing i'm amazed i'm it's it's
it's
a very interesting story and it's one
that i'm following very closely
six million uh members of the forum
right now did you ever expect that when
you started it would grow to be that big
you know i the the forum has been
doubling in size for the first eight
years
and uh just to be clear i'm no longer a
moderator as of
april of last year um but every year it
had doubled in size pretty predictably
and this year apparently seems to be
blowing this out of the water i mean i
know that on all the other social media
platforms that we're on i got twitter
and there's that
youtube the the number of uh uh
followers and interests is growing in an
astoundingly astounding manner so no i
did not
anticipate that at least not not so
quickly and not
not so not with an event so spectacular
you've got some attention of of some
huge name i mean names elon musk of
course uh
wealthiest man in the world chamoth
paulo hapatia
kathy wood of arc investments um
what do you have to say to them right
now
i mean yeah they're chiming in from from
a perspective that i don't think anyone
ever anticipated or planned you know
everyone that's been
involved with wall street beds is always
just trying to make some money or have
have some fun with the market just like
this uh gentleman that was interviewed
before i came
on that's that's a decent profile of it
what ends up happening
is as these guys pull off this
spectacular trade that continues to
unfold they take out this fund and
the the dialogue kind of changes right
the narrative uh is very inviting and is
there's a bit of a poetic justice feel
to it where the little guy is beating
the big guy
and that's where you're getting
attention from these high-profile
individuals
as well as from uh politicians right i i
was surprised to find out that
uh aoc elizabeth warren
uh ted cruz and i guess donald trump
trump jr who's not in the government but
still kind of
has a voice for it they all agree on
this situation right like for the first
time they're holding hands
that's that's to me something that's
pretty amazing i think it's because it's
starting a conversation
that is overdue well so so what do you
think the the result of that
conversation should be i mean
as as an early participant in this as
the founder i mean
do you do you think that there needs to
be regulation uh
around what we saw happen this week look
i i definitely think that the
conversation needs to be had you know
we've had
many moments in the recent history of
the us
where uh when changes take effect you
know i'm thinking about
gay marriage rights or marijuana
legalization it all starts with a
conversation like this and it leads to
to a process of democracy um i i don't
know where at least i don't know that
it's regulation right so some people are
taking the
perspective of regulation you know this
is wrong these prices are incorrect
uh i agree i i haven't fully made up my
mind as to whether this is
outright manipulation the way that it's
defined or pump and dump the way it is
defined
but i do agree that it's that there's
something strange going on but even
before this
a lot of strange things were going on so
i think there needs to be some
regulation
that strength strengthens the system of
wall street what we saw yesterday
with the brokers that have the castle
trading shows the weakness of this and i
also feel that there needs to be
regulation
uh to be able to empower the individuals
for too long the big uh investment firms
the big wall street players have had all
the control and i think that there needs
to
level the playing field well to that end
i think a lot of people have been
wondering what the goal for wall street
bets users
are i know you're not affiliated with it
anymore but are they trying to take down
wall street are they
money hungry i mean you started it so
what is the collective goal
i i i did and i've done many things uh
in the history to try and instigate
these types of conversations
uh but by doing very outlandish things i
was
before coronavirus planning on doing
this esports style trading competition
where we literally turned this activity
into a video game
uh but we're using actual money in the
real stock market hoping to spark a
little bit of this
you know i don't personally don't have a
necessary goal but i definitely wanted
people to be able to see
the ludicrousness of some of the things
that are possible
uh and i also don't think that wall
street vets had a
big plan in mind it's a disorganized
structure
i think that this narrative starting to
construct the moment this melvin capital
went down
uh that's when people realize that they
have the ability to change but i don't
know if it's a take down wall street
they're also participating everyone
anyone that touches wall street wants to
make money that's how you know it's the
end of the story
and they can't take out the other guys
because then they can't make money
and one of the the realities is not
everyone who touches it ends up making
money we saw some big stories of some
massive losses this week
especially earlier in the week with some
hedge funds
i anticipate jamie just because the way
things are going that we are going to
start seeing stories
of some retail investors who've lost
money on this or
will lose money on this how do you feel
knowing that
you helped create a forum where where
this was possible i mean do you
do you feel bad for anyone who's lost
money look i
i i agree with you absolutely and wall
street bits is one of the few places
where showing loss of money is not a
shameful thing and it's a
not necessarily a badge of honor but
it's welcome people have this refreshing
uh sense of honesty uh so you will be
seeing some of those stories
uh you know the fact is since the stock
market's invention
um for every time there's a trade you
have a person that or
a party that makes money in a party that
loses money it is a zero-sum game if
you're just looking at the dollars and
cents and not going too abstract
so there's nothing new here right so if
we're talking about
uh more people that are participating
and more people that can make it lose
money
i don't really feel much about that i'll
be honest with you my personal opinion
when someone loses a lot of money
i kind of feel a little bit bad but
they're all adults they're responsible
and i feel good about the fact that
they're spreading the word that this is
still a risky
uh venture what's much more dangerous
and makes me lose a lot more sleep is
when people make a lot of money
in a high profile way because then
people forget about the risks and then
they start dreaming and then they can
fall
into a track um i want to get your
thoughts on on you said you've gotten a
lot of
calls this week um in the wall street
journal uh
profile of you i saw that andrew left
from citron research has called you we
learned this morning citron research is
discontinuing its short-selling research
after doing this for decades
um who else has reached out to you this
week
uh a lot of people big names a lot of
people big names from a lot of different
industries from a lot of different
places who are some of those big names
i can't tell you hedge fund managers
you name the industry and they've
reached out are you going to work with
them
i have my job i've always had my job you
know like wall street bets has always
kind of been a hobby i tried to make a
i'm telling you this this trading
competition last year and
you know hopefully make a project out of
that but coronavirus did what it did to
the whole world
um i don't plan on on changing my
trajectory opportunities arise
i'll explore them but i'm i'm i'm happy
with what i do
okay last question jamie as we heard
from john arthur's uh who's watched the
market for
decades this is a an absolutely historic
week years from now there could be
courses and books written about what
happened this week there could even be a
movie
if there's a movie who plays you
uh i don't know i guess we'll have to
cast that out there i haven't really
thought about that
all right we'll let the twitter first
decide that that sounds like a good
thing
maybe you know maybe jamie rogozinski
founder of wall street bets jamie thank
you for your time we really appreciate
it
well coming up what do gamestop
employees think of
their company all over the news this
week well we went to a store to find out
we'll be back in two minutes this is
take a break
[Music]
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
our generation's biggest problem climate
change
is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions
transport industry uh buildings
electricity all of those things
everything you need to know about our
changing environment the politics of
global warming
we can and we will deal with climate
change in the fight against climate
change
bloomberg green has you covered
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to this special edition of
take a break the reddit revolution i'm
tim stenoveck in new york
while the drama over gamestop unfolded
on reddit and twitter its brick and
mortar stores were business as usual
quick takes erica eric erawa uku headed
out to her local game stop in oakland
california
to see what the store's customers are
making of the headlines
members of the sub reddit group have
been going to war this week with some of
the world's richest
hedge fund managers over this gamestop
is one of the world's largest video game
retailers for playstation xbox nintendo
and much more but lately they struggled
with just how easy it is for customers
to download
games directly to their computers and
consoles now i'm about to go inside of
my local game stop see what people are
making of this news
and while it has a nice coat of paint
you wouldn't be able to tell that this
store was valued at 23 billion but let's
see what books are shopping for
[Music]
i was shopping today to look for a gift
from my son i'm just looking for pokemon
cards i'm shopping for a playstation 2.
gamestop has made headlines this week
[Music]
are you familiar with why uh yeah i've
seen that they were
making headlines with the stock get
blowing up just going crazy
stock price sirs i have no clue about i
do know
bitcoin is going to fight at me yeah
that number seems
really really hot for gamestop hitting
that uh
that big number i think it tells me that
um big things are to come
but again i'm not highly educated on the
reasons to ask why
it seemed like some of that money could
be going to you know should be going to
a good cause
maybe they can contribute to um you know
the vaccinations you know i don't really
care too much about what happens on the
stock market but
i'm glad to hear though that uh you know
things are going well for the company so
that's good
i mean a lot of people play games i mean
it's a lucrative uh
investment these days with everybody
staying home i guess
gaming is on the rise uh i wouldn't be
surprised because everybody's into
gaming
even folks my age my thoughts on
gamestop being around much longer i
would say yeah
um there really isn't much more other
stories to kind of get your video game
stuff for this right here just
concentrates on what you came here for
i think he'll be around for a long time
especially at times right now because
we're in a pandemic so many kids are at
home
and so many other people are discovering
games i mean he's just great he got all
the games
i'm looking to revisit games like crash
bandicoot
you like that game yeah vintage stuff so
just want to go back in time for a
little bit you know just visit the
childhood
yeah i don't i don't think gamestop has
a future i think it's all going to be
digital at some point i love coming here
hopefully it's still rough
the news about gamestop and the stock it
doesn't change anything for me
personally
as a consumer you know i'm always going
to want to come here if i'm looking for
anything video game related for myself
and my kids
our thanks to erwa ooku for that report
well coming up next you asked and we're
going to answer our markets reporter
sarah poncec
answers this week's most frequently
asked questions for people with little
market exposure we'll be back in two
minutes this
is take a break
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our generation's biggest problem climate
change
is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions
transport industry uh buildings
electricity
all of those things everything you need
to know about our changing environment
the politics of global warming we can
and we will deal with climate change
in the fight against climate change
boomer green has you covered
[Music]
welcome back to this special edition of
take a break the reddit revolution i'm
tim stenovec in new york well
if your group texts were blowing up
about the markets
and the memes this week you are
definitely not alone if a lot of them
included advice from novice traders who
had no idea what they were talking about
you are
definitely not alone but good thing we
got sarah ponceck
here with me now to break down the
frequently asked questions of the week
sarah um awesome to have you back on the
show we reached out to our
reddit or to our community talk who was
talking about reddit we reached out to
our community who's been following this
story
we have lots of questions for you they
asked us the questions on
on uh instagram we got them on instagram
but i got to ask you this basic question
before we get to those why should
somebody who's who's not like a regular
participant in the market who doesn't
follow this
the market story week to week why should
they care about what happened the one
i've got to say my group texts we're
also blowing up this week and
a lot of people who don't typically pay
attention to markets but they're texting
the right person
yeah yeah i'm not answering their
questions
but why should people beyond those
participating in the stock market
pay attention to this john arthur's got
into this a little bit earlier on in the
show
and it's that this is almost a cultural
moment we think about a decade ago
and the occupy wall street movement it
was a movement that
really came back to the concept of
economic inequality
and that's really what the basis of this
is or at least that at least that's what
a lot of people
want you to believe for example if you
were to go
on wall street bets there are many posts
about
experiences that users had back in 2008
during the financial crisis
how they came to really be angry with
the wall street establishment and hedge
funds especially hedge funds who are
taking active short positions and hoping
that a company will fail
so what this really boils down to is
this cultural moment where
there's this tug of war between what
some look at as the little guy the
retail trader and the big guy the wall
street establishment
and at the same time it's not just
traders
and those on reddit on twitter who are
paying attention i mean
you've got big politicians you've got
the sec i mean there are multiple people
paying attention now um
sarah one question that we got in a lot
of different ways
was about short selling i think a lot of
people understand the concept of buying
a stock at a certain price holding it
for a period of time and then selling it
for for more
or for less but we heard a lot about
shorting this week with regard
to hedge funds that had shorted certain
stocks like like gamestop so very basic
question
what is a short so i'll explain it to
you this way one in order to short a
stock it has to be done in a margin
account because you're
borrowing that stock from someone else
so the way this works is
a short seller will borrow a stock from
someone who holds the stock and they
hope that
they will be able to sell the stock and
buy it back
at a cheaper price so say you short a
stock you borrow it at 80
a share it falls to 11 and
you are able to buy it back at 11 you
profit that difference you profit on the
stock falling
that way then at the end of it you
return the stock back to the person you
borrowed it from so
you have to borrow the stock and
essentially you profit from the
differential
between the price you borrowed it at and
what you eventually sell it
and the flip side of that is if the
stock price doesn't fall like we saw
with gamestop this week
you get squeezed right you have
unlimited losses if a stock is rising
if you are short the stock which is
exactly what happened with these hedge
funds this week and they lost billions
of dollars okay um
question now from a lot of people a lot
of people ask this one uh
is it wrong for a group of people let's
say friends to buy stocks together after
discussing it on forums
you mean the legal question yeah yeah so
this is a big one
uh technically and it's a really
difficult question
for securities lawyers for the sec if
you're just getting together with a
group of friends and you all say
hey let's buy this stock at this time
together technically there's nothing
illegal about that
it's really only illegal if there's
false information being spread or
non-public information
all right very good stuff sarah poncec
thank you so much for breaking it all
down we have so many more questions that
we couldn't get to unfortunately we are
out of time that's going to do it for
quick take this hour check out the
latest stories at bloomberg.com right
quick take on social media
i'm tim stenovec have a great day
everyone we will see you at 4 30.